but lured me to Berlin was this big city
and not knowing what would come next and
of course it was all garnished with love
Johanna Nussbaum was born in Salzburg
Austria in 1969 the second of two
children she lived in the countryside
with her grandparents for several years
in 2001 she moved to Berlin for love for
seven years she gained experience
working in restaurants in the German
capital then she opened her own
restaurant new Spelman my grandmother
had a farm as a child I was allowed to
watch when an animal was butchered not
when it was killed but afterwards when
it was being processed nothing was
wasted
something was made out of everything
fascinated me so much that I said I want
to become a cook he's moved again a
cooking with Johanna Nussbaum are
trained to be a chef at the restaurant
in Schmauss official a luxury hotel in
western Austria here she learned to cook
regional dishes as the chef of her own
restaurant she cherishes the traditional
cuisine of the Salzburg region she likes
to dig up old recipes and add
refinements of her own it's not them I'm
Funke this is Lingle when I first opened
I made Luna it's made from heart and
lung and it's an awful lot of work and
it really saddens me that the guests
wouldn't order it they avoided organ
meats afraid they get sick yes - how
much weight not I feel but in Austria
it's a country and doesn't have the guys
on its menus people won't go there
because it's proof yes the owner can't
cook
so nussbaumer took Lenin and other organ
meat dishes off of her menu instead she
relies on classics like Wiener schnitzel
Salzburg beer flies is a tremendous hit
in her restaurant miss Falmer prepares
it according to an old family recipe the
core of the recipe is the sauce all the
ingredients are used in their entirety
even the peels of the vegetables come
into the stalk
the seasonings are crushed in a mortar
and pestle to release all their aroma
beer has been brewed in the Salzburg
region for hundreds of years it's a
tradition that has influenced the
regional cuisine
the beer gives the roasts its name only
dark beer with a high malt content wa
boo all the ingredients are brought to a
boil allowed to simmer for a while and
then left to marinate for 24 hours
that gives the broth intense flavor for
the sauce Austrian cuisine is hearty and
Salzburg beer flesh is a popular winter
dish this bomber serves hers with
dumplings and blanched carrots is a
recipe from my grandmother's people cook
it a lot in the Salzburg region but with
pork we've altered that a bit of using
veal because veal is less fatty and
easier to digest
don't forget that in past times
farmhands and peasants worked hard in
the fields and needed more fat on food
today not so much be hungry be thirsty
be welcome debts misnomers motto and she
says it's typical of Austria
she says the ambience is very important
and must reflect style and good taste
a portrait of her grandmother hangs on
the wall this helps una skimmed when I
played Monopoly as a child I always
tried to buy the street quo fierce and
dumb in Berlin so the core for us and
dumb always interested me and now to
have a restaurant right next to it feels
right Western Berlin is simply very
dignified and refined like old Vienna in
the 16th century the Kurfurstendamm
connected the berlin city palace with a
royal hunting lodge outside the city in
grew Nevada the Kerr first or Prince
elector used to ride along it with his
entourage
when Berlin was divided it became the
main shopping Boulevard in West Berlin
today the khuddam as Berliners call it
is still a popular street for boutiques
and restaurants the restaurant dispell
marine named for the owner is unlike
natasa a side street the site saw four
previous restaurants fail before Johanna
Nussbaum er set up shop word quickly got
around that there was an outstanding
Austrian restaurant in charlotte book
and she has been booked out ever since
christmas greetings today i prepared
some salzburg beer flesh for you and now
enjoy